[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique on
parle aujourd'hui de la sécheresse des
conséquences pour les agriculteurs et
des conséquences aussi pour nous
habitants et consommateurs de la
bourgogne franche comté
trois invités aujourd'hui sur le plateau
thierry chalmin c'est le président de la
chambre d'agriculture de la haute saône
face à lui se fit fonquernie
vice-présidente au conseil régional en
charge de l'agriculture
et puis christian decerle c'est le
président de la chambre régionale
d'agriculture pour la bourgogne et la
franche comté
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez réagir sur
twitter grâce au hashtag dit mme paul
bfc comme dimension politique bourgogne
franche comté
on commence cette émission par deux
photos qui illustrent bien les dégâts
d'un été très chaud et surtout sans plus
sur notre région le saut du doubs
aviaire le lac la chute d'eau n'existe
plus normalement l'eau tombe d'une
hauteur de 27 mètres d'un lot il y en a
plus et le doubs peu après sa source
entre pontarlier et morteau là non plus
la rivière n'existe plus sur des
kilomètres le lit de la rivière est à
sec
les passants font des statuts en
superposant les pierres les unes sur les
autres
un petit peu comme une incantation pour
que la pluie tombe alors on va commencer
par à un tour de table
déjà avec vous thierry chalmin on dit
que c'est du jamais vu mais concrètement
pour vous ça veut dire quoi
compte tenu du fait que la haute saône
et le département de bourgogne franche
comté le plus touché par cette
sécheresse vous céréaliers ça veut dire
aussi dans nos systèmes polyculture
élevage d automne
une difficulté qui a quasiment triplé
puisque polyculture élevage à venir des
animaux qui sont mal nourris ou
difficilement nourrit depuis le mois de
juillet ça veut dire pour les
productions végétales une deuxième mois
son maïs soja tournesol etc avec des
rendements divisé par deux et puis ça
veut aussi surtout lire des difficultés
d'implantation de toutes les cultures
pour l'année prochaine cette fois ci
puisque la sole de colza va être très
handicapée par la sécheresse qu'on a
connu et puis les cultures d'automne blé
est hors jeu qui vient d'être implanté
ont pour l'instant beaucoup de
difficultés à germer parce que pas assez
donc vous les sdc mais en attendant que
la pluie arrive et la pluie arrive ces
jours ci les semis ont été faits on a en
attente de l'eau pour que les graines
germées quoi alors ce fichu dernier vous
vous êtes agricultrice à seulement sur
le massif du lomu dans le doubs au
dessus de pont de roide et vous
produisez du blé à morbier est ce que
ces sécheresses ça veut dire moins de
lait produit sur votre exploitation
c'est évident en a beau donner des
stocks qui était prévu normalement pour
le pour l'hiver c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas la qualité de l'herbe et
surtout les usa et donner du foin et de
la paille directement dans les champs du
point du foin en vain avant qu'elle ne
sorte le matin le soir et mais ce n'est
pas suffisant parce que ça n'a pas la
qualité de l'herbe et puis surtout la
canicule fait qu'il est bête reste dans
un bois dans un bosquet elles
n'embauchent plus et donc elles vont pas
elles devront pas explorer n'est pas
concrètement ça veut dire quel
pourcentage de lait en moins pour vous
assure l'été on peut dire 25% un quart
de moins de lait même si on les a
soutenus des bêtes ça se nourrit on peut
pas laisser des bêtes sans les nourrir
ça se nourrit donc on a attaqué très
fortement les stocks de divers mais
malgré tout il ya une baisse de la juste
deux chiffres pour qu'on se fasse une
idée du climat de ce qui s'est passé au
mois de septembre sur la région
c'est + 2 degrés par rapport aux
moyennes relevé d'habitude on est au
mois de septembre
et c'est moins 80% depuis lors christian
decerle vous vous êtes éleveur de
charolais dans le morvan saône et loire
à la guiche
ça veut dire quoi concrètement pour vous
cette sécheresse 2018
écoutez concrètement déjà le secteur de
l'élevage traverse depuis plusieurs
années à une situation assez difficile
sur un plan des démarches et des cours
peut être aussi sur un plan plus de la
perception moral de l'agriculteur et de
l'éleveur sur les critiques qui sont
formulées à ce métier
donc cette sécheresse arrive sur un
terreau économique et moral déjà un peu
fragilisé et évidemment on ouvre l'hiver
est une période sensible délicate pour
un troupeau pour un éleveur avec des ce
taux très insuffisant et de nourriture
de nourriture on met trop de bête
comment et peut-être de galice en tout
cas il ya un décalage une inadéquation
entre le stock et le nombre d'animaux
c'est sûr et des trésoreries qui sont
très fragiles et qui permettent pas même
si on trouvait sur le marché d'acheter
les volumes d'alimentation de tous leurs
besoins
s'il existe si lisez ceci existe alors
quelques chiffres pour montrer le poids
de l'agriculture dans notre région en
bourgogne franche comté
sachez tout d'abord que c'est 50 % de la
superficie totale de notre région et qui
lie à 27000 exploitations agricoles et
puis la grue l'agriculture et l'agro
alimentaire pèse lourd également dans
l'économie en bourgogne franche comté
puisque l'agriculture c'est 5,8
milliards d'euros produit chaque année
et l'agroalimentaire ses 6,8 milliards
alors on donc on voit c'est moins de
lait par exemple c'est des fourrages qui
manqueront pour l'hiver mais par exemple
concrètement on a vu beaucoup
d'inquiétude pour une filiale vous vous
produisez du las à morbier mais dans
votre secteur
on produit beaucoup de lait à comté
est-ce qu'on peut s'inquiéter pour le
compte est ce qu'il va y avoir une
pénurie de compte et non globalement je
m'en suis ouverte aux responsables de la
filière il y a c'est très inégale dans
les parties des plus hautes il ya eu des
orages j'ai eu un peu de pluie
il ya eu il s'est fait dès deuxième
coupe de regain est donc globalement je
pense pas que la baisse sera importante
au niveau des aop chez plus de soucis
pour toutes les zones dans les standards
où les prix sont moindres et
comme par exemple la haute saône ou la
saône et loire est où là il ya des
baisses importantes et avec une
difficulté trésorerie à la clé très
fortement donc le lait standard s'est
par exemple dans votre département la
haute saône pour des paysans qui
produisent du lait standard ça veut dire
beaucoup moins de l'est beaucoup moins
de rentrées d'argent et peut-être aussi
à l'aide de moins bonne qualité
ça veut dire tout ça effectivement ça
veut dire moins de lait - de production
mais ça veut dire aussi celui qui a
produit coûte beaucoup plus cher à
produire puisque les animaux comme l'a
dit sophie tout à l'heure l'herbe
absente des pâturages depuis le mois de
juillet donc il faut complémenter
beaucoup plus pour avoir une production
quand même suffisante tant les camps
vient complémenter ça veut dire apporter
un complément un aliment menacé d'un
fourrage et quoi donc
donc il faut il faut il faut nourrir les
animaux que ce soit en laye où on vient
aussi les broutards voilà les broutards
ont perdu par rapport au poids moyens
normaux 40 à 50 kg voilà tout ça c'est
des rentrées kiki qui n'arrive pas et ça
coûte très cher parce que ce qu'on
achète à l'extérieur de l'exploitation
cette année des prix exorbitants qu'on
ne peut justement on va en parler de ce
groupe
ya pas trop de solidarité autres vous
entre entre les paysans c'est pas une
histoire de solidarité c'est une
histoire qu'on a eu un manque de chance
énorme
la moisson s'est faite en france
quasiment en une semaine aussi bien
haute saône que dans la marne comme
beaucoup de régions on n'a pas le temps
même si on a été très précoce dans nos
dans nos réactions
on n'a pas forcément eu le temps de
pouvoir réserver par exemple la paille
qui nous manque énormément franche-comté
aujourd'hui à nos collègues de la marne
de la haute-marne ou d'ailleurs de
l'aube
parce qu'il est en moi sans même temps
que nous il faut se rappeler aussi que
au 14 juillet la moisson est quasiment
terminée pour tout ce qui est du jamais
vu ce qui n'aide jamais vu alors
monsieur dessert vous vous êtes donc
éleveur de charolais vous faites de la
viande est ce que les cours de la viande
baisse malheureusement il était déjà pas
très haut
les catégories d'animaux qui sont les
plus touchés c'est ce qu'on appelle les
animaux maigres jeudi maigre entre
guillemets c'est à dire les animaux
qu'on a pour habitude de finir
d'engraisser pour qu'ils soient destinés
à la boucherie
donc ces animaux là qui mériterait
d'être engraisser sur place et dans
l'exploitation
n'ayant pas de stock on les met sur le
marché il ya une abondance d'animaux qui
arrivent de façon inattendue
il ya l'offre et il n'y a pas la demande
est là les cours s'effondrent
donc ça touche génisses vaches de
réforme et broutards comme vient de le
dire thierry d'eisai broutin c'est des
animaux qu'on élève exprès peau pour la
viande il y as en bourgogne franche
comté 2 millions de bovins presque
autant que d'habitants sur sur notre
région
malgré tout cette baisse de la viande on
la voit pas chez le boucher
c'est une côté consommateurs qui parle
là monsieur de sel à écouter on va
l'avoir
non je crains que on voit les cours à la
production baisser pour ne pas dire dans
certaines catégories d'animaux
s'effondrer sans que pour autant le
consommateur de fait ne puissent en
bénéficier
parce que tout ça est d'une grande
complexité il ya de l'inertie ya en tout
cas on le remarque certains
intermédiaires qui peuvent aussi en
profiter un peu voilà il ya une
promptitude à tirer parti des situations
qui fragilise et producteurs sans
forcément avoir la volonté d'en faire
bénéficier le consommateur mais tout ça
est complexe souci alors vous conseil
régional vous êtes dans dans la réforme
territoriale ce qu'on appelle le chef de
file de l'économie quelles sont les
aides
que vous avez apporté que vous allez
apporter au conseil régional
à quelle hauteur et comment et pourquoi
ben comment dire le travail déjà de fin
juillet mois déjà fin juillet jehanno
j'ai téléphoné à la présidente de région
lui disant à la situation est grave elle
n'a fait qu'empirer tout le mois d'août
comme on l'a vu au mois de septembre
et donc nous nous avions la présidente
avait pris contact avec les présidents
de départements et qu'ils étaient prêts
à aider les agriculteurs mais qui ne
savait pas comment faire du fait de la
loi
notre et et il fallait un cadre donc
nous avons pris l'initiative d'offrir ce
cadre pour c'est un peu technique et
dire qu'en fait vous avez vous été
entendu avec les départements qui n'ont
plus la compétence économique a est donc
aisé faisait avant c'est dix millions
dix millions dix millions d'euros qui
vont être mis sur du court terme est sur
du moyen terme donc 5 millions en aide
directe pour les exploitations d'élevage
impacté et donc avec les départements et
puis ensuite à moyen terme puis sur de
l'investissement parce qu'il va falloir
réfléchir à peut-être faire plus de deux
bâtiments de stockage pour stocker
davantage de fourrage quand c'est
possible pour ces périodes pense qu on
sent bien qu'ils vont être récurrente et
on va demander de ces assises est un
formidable mouvement de solidarité de
toutes les collectivités de la région
département et région monsieur de cl
vous dites quoi bravo vous êtes contents
vous vous êtes entendus jeudi déjà que
malheureusement malheureusement jamais
ni l'intervention publique jamais
l'intervention publique ne sait se
substituer à ce que la nature d'une part
où les marchés ne nous ont pas donné
ceci étant dit je crois que la
profession dans son ensemble salue
l'intervention initié par le conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté et
la volonté des collectivités de nos
conseils départementaux de s'être
alignés dans une vision globale
cohérente
autrement dit a pas eu de mesquinerie ou
de chamailleries il ya une volonté des
élus qu'ils soient de l'échelon régional
ou de l'échelon départemental
et quelle que soit leur couleur
politique et quelle que soit leur
sensibilité politique de venir soutenir
un secteur économique qui n'est pas que
l'exploitation agricole mais qui est
bien toute une économie rurale qui
gravitent autour de la cl de lait s'est
aussi dit les candides du territoriales
et que ça commence ici tellement on a vu
didier guillaume le nouveau ministre de
l'agriculture dans la muse meuse
cette semaine annoncé des z vous
réagissez comme en bas j'ai réagi déjà
ce qui vient d'être dit par rapport à
les heroes soutien des collectivités
territoriales moi aussi je salue les
efforts du conseil régional
des départements a priori c'est la
première région de france qui se
mobilisent je pense que j'avance le
blanche après faut relativiser tout ça
alors ça peut choquer un certain nombre
de nos auditeurs aujourd'hui dire 10
millions d'euros dead encore des
subventions aux paysans
l'entente jeunes entend régulièrement
relativisons quand même dans une
exploitation moyenne de nos départements
ça va faire un billet d'aller à tout
casser 1000 euros le plus quoi donc
voila quand on dit du tout ça c'est vrai
que ça fait pas beaucoup mais on avait
besoin on avait besoin nous agriculteurs
de ce soutien qui a aussi quelque chose
de psychologique de savoir nous
agriculteurs que à côté de nous dans la
difficulté nous avons notre collectivité
conseil régional et nous département
pour nous aider ça me fait aussi du bien
voilà donc après sur les décisions
allaient les annonces qui ont été faites
par le ministre de l'agriculture suite à
sa visite en mieux je crois
la mesure est malheureusement la
boutique et là j'ai un peu l'impression
qui a pas tellement grand chose de
nouveau quoi on nous parle
éventuellement d'une enveloppe de 15
millions d'euros niveau national sur des
allègements de charges sociales
est-ce que c'est du recyclage de quelque
chose qui existait déjà ce que c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
je n'en sais rien le ministre insiste
sur la vence des aides pac bon sexe est
finalement ces deux là il faudrait quand
même que les paysans dans votre
département haute saône ont décidé de ne
pas payer leurs cotisations sociales à
aimer ça là c'est parce qu'il ne pleuve
pas ils ne le peuvent pas dans les expos
tories n'ont plus assez d'argent
le peu de trésorerie qui va être
disponible dans les exploitations en
dessous mais c'est vrai certainement
aussi ailleurs c'est pas comme zone
le bad ou le belge aura enfin tous les
départements soit à peu près dans la
même situation
le peu de trésorerie qui a dans les
exploitations aujourd'hui va être
destiné à nourrir les animaux à vil prix
ça a été dit par l'ensemble de mes
collègues aujourd'hui la la la la la la
nourriture coûte énormément cher le peu
de trésorerie qu'on va voir ça sera
certes pas pour payer des cotisations
sociales ce sera pour acheter un peu de
nourriture pour nos animaux pour essayer
bon an mal an le plus le moins mal
possible de gagner le printemps prochain
de passer l'hiver
alors je vous propose maintenant de
parler un petit peu de l'avenir et de la
nécessaire adaptation de notre
agriculture avec un petit retour en
arrière
il est beaucoup question de la
sécheresse de 1976 pour faire des
comparaisons
alors notre région était l'une des une
région touchée en 1976 voici quelques
extraits de reportages justement de
cette année la regarder si la région
franc-comtoise n'est pas la plus touchée
des provinces françaises par la
sécheresse la situation est néanmoins
critique en certains endroits le front
est abondant certes mais le regain fera
défaut et certains agriculteurs
subissent déjà une baisse de 50% de la
production du lait des villages sont
privés d'eau tels malbrande dans le
doubs la perte la plus sensible c'est se
ressent sur les productions fourragères
puisque suivant les secteurs la première
coupe de foin subi une baisse de 30 à
50% et la deuxième coupe les regards de
50 à 100% puisqu'elle est nul dans
beaucoup de secteurs l'agriculture
française ps de tous
poids dans l'économie mais elles ne se
place pas au même niveau que les autres
secteurs d'activité sa richesse est liée
au temps l'équilibré est fragile mais
avec une sécheresse catastrophique par
siècle
on a tendance à de plus en tenir compte
[Musique]
une sécheresse catastrophique par siècle
disait le journaliste
on a eu 49 on a eu donc 76
on a eu 2003 on a aujourd'hui 2018 ça a
tendance à s'accélérer
il y à 18 mois vous avez créé une
commission à la chambre régionale pour
justement envisagé l'adaptation de
l'agriculture
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour vous
demander vos recettes mais déjà le fait
que vous y pensiez
ça veut dire que ça vous inquiète et qui
va falloir faire quelque chose écoutez
ce ce métier plus que d'autres et
complètement tributaires de la météo des
évolutions météo
je crois que nul et quel qu'en soit son
origine d'ailleurs ne peut aujourd'hui
contester une évolution climatique qui
préoccupait donald trump qui dit oui à
l'envers voilà ça paraît une évidence et
ce générateur de beaucoup d'inquiétudes
et de beaucoup d'angoissé mais
concrètement ça veut dire quoi pour nous
ça veut dire qu'on va devoir changer nos
productions notre façon de faire en
agriculteurs et aussi en consommation ça
veut dire que il nous d'abord ça nous
rappelle que nous devrions faire preuve
d'une grande humilité et que la nature
via de nous rappeler cette année encore
quelle quand elle reprend ses droits ça
peut être très lourdes conséquences
il ya la sécheresse chez nous il ya les
inondations dramatiques dans d'autres
régions
et un bouleversement climatique qui nous
intérêts qui nous interpelle je pense
que c'est une question qui est posée à
l'agriculture évidemment mais au delà
comme vous le dites à l'ensemble de la
société
sanou réinterroge vous avez raison sur
nos modèles en sachant que le déficit
d'eau était jeune première problématique
l'excès de température en est une
deuxième tout aussi inquiétante des
températures qui dépassent plusieurs
jours consécutifs des 40 42 43 degrés ça
pose des questions
plus rapidement que nous ne sommes
capables de trouver les réponses alors
vous êtes un peu pris de vitesse et ça
c'est à dire c'est un peu une course
contre la montre où on va savoir sans
doute infléchir un certain nombre
d'initiatives en mobilisant toutes les
compétences des savoirs de la recherche
de l'observation de voilà mais ça ça
demande aussi d'aborder cette question
de l'adaptation de notre agriculture
avec sans a priori et sans dogmatisme ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que il
faut laisser aussi la recherche la
possibilité d'aller jusqu'au bout de
s'exprimer et de pouvoir tirer des
enseignements de ce qu'elle nous allons
enseigner
thierry chalmin vous êtes producteur de
céréales en haute saône est ce que ça
veut dire que vous allez changer de
céréales vous allez peut-être plus faire
de maïs qui consomme trop d'eau mais
peut-être faire du sorgho comme en
afrique
peut-être que oui mais enfin vous avez
remonter là sur le reportage à 1976 moi
je me suis intéressé ce matin à remonter
beaucoup moins loin que ça alors ce qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement cette sécheresse christian
nadi couplée à des températures
quand même extrêmement néfaste pour les
animaux ou les plantes est les humains
mi 2012
gel des céréales je suis mon département
de l'aude sont une bonne partie de la
sole de céréales d'hiver gelé au
printemps nous qu'on recommence 2015
une petite sécheresse d'automne qui a
quand même déjà à l'époque justifier des
aides de notre conseil départemental
sécheresse quand même 2016 inondations
pas de rayonnement pas de rendement très
très mauvaise moisson en 2016 nous
disions faut que vous sachiez les
moissons du siècle vous que vous changez
de métier vous voulez le servir aussi je
suis nulle 2017 2017
allez on va considérer que 2010 est
l'année a été peu près correct sauf que
des prix
ras les pâquerettes 2018 la sécheresse
qu'on connaît donc l'adaptation
elle doit effectivement être prendre en
compte la qualité que nous venons de
subir mais aussi tout le reste depuis
six ans il se passe pas une année sûr
qu'on a un éclatement ça veut dire quoi
pour vous des céréales vous
le maïs vous laissez moi on va enlever
le maïs pour b du sorgho peut-être
faut-il qu'on y réfléchisse je constate
quand même que cette année les systèmes
les plus pénalisées ce sont les systèmes
à base d'herbes et et que le maïs
encore une fois même s'il est décrié par
un certains nombres de nos concitoyens
je rappelle quand même qu'en
franche-comté le maïs que nous plantons
il ne vit qu'avec l'eau qui tombe du
ciel
il n'est pas il apparaît mécaniquement
dans mon voit dans d'autres régions très
limitrophes il y vit avec l'eau qui
tombe du ciel
le maïs va encore une fois contribué à
sauver une partie de l'alimentation de
nos troupeaux laitiers ou viande donc le
maïs c'est quand même une plante
intéressante pour ça peut-être faut-il
qu'on se dirige vers des nouvelles
productions des nouvelles plantes le
sorgho ça est une piste mais ça sera
certainement pas la panacée et le scot
cancan monsieur de celle d'il faut pas
voir derrière ça veut dire ça ça veut
dire il faut être prêt à tout il faut
être prêt à tout mais vous savez une
année comme celle qu'on vient de vivre
qui a compliqué et quand j'entends nos
collègues viticulteurs dire que même la
vigne a souffert du trop chaud et du
trop sec est pourtant la visite ans et
pourtant il va chercher loin à begnins
oui et puis pourtant ils sont contents
de la quantité et de la qualité et vous
en tant que conseil régional vous pouvez
apporter qu'elle aide pour justement
aider les paysans à s'adapter
justement on n'a pas attendu cette
sécheresse là pour réagir l'an dernier
nous avons travaillé avec la profession
agricole les chambres d'agriculture
autour d'une stratégie partagée jeu
pourra permettre aux exploitations de
s'adapter aux filières de s'adapter et
ça veut dire par exemple pour les
exploitations
elle peut faire un audit avec des gens
un peu expert pour savoir quoi produire
demain sur quel de confettis manque
voilà un accompagnement la réflexion sur
l'installation nous devrons mener aussi
la réflexion parce que c'est clair que
quelqu'un qui s'installent pour
plusieurs décennies
il va devoir réfléchir à quel type de
production il va faire sur son
exploitation pour les filières c'est
pareil verrait simplement on devra on
avance déjà là dessus on a dû travailler
avec l'inra institut national de
recherche agronomique pour essayer
d'avoir des systèmes plus résilient aux
aléas climatiques c'était les plus
résistants plus résistants
avec une part de polyculture-élevage ses
associés élevage avec les cultures une
façon qu'est-ce qu'il ya un aléa
climatique qu'ils ne touchent pas toute
l'activité de l'agriculteur ci fait 15
et qu'une seule production c'est ça oui
l'idée d'entamer tous ses oeufs dans le
même panier un petit peu ça et demi de
travailler avec des cycles de vie est-ce
que financièrement vous êtes prêt à
apporter de l'argent aux agriculteurs
justement qui voudraient partir sur des
productions sur des modèles de femmes
qui ne sont pas parce qu'on le fait déjà
par le biais des audits c'est à dire que
dans chaque chaque exploitation est
différente
il ya une réponse différente dans
mélodique c'est vous qui payez ou celles
agricoles
c'est en grande partie la région qui
paye il ya une faible part qui revient
l'agriculteur et ça permet de ne pas se
trouver face à un mur face aux aléas
économiques ou climatiques c'est-à-dire
de se redonner des perspectives qui a
changé quelque peu le système de
production et il ya aussi je fais
termine avec ce tout ce travail que nous
avons fait ensemble
et à la question de travailler aussi
avec les territoires sur la question de
l'eau on a vu qu'il y avait des communes
qui est tellement vraiment en manque
d'eau très fort j'ai une question j'ai
une question d'un téléspectateur c'est
robert dans le territoire de belfort qui
dit pourquoi on ne fait pas plus de
stockage d'eau en période quand
justement ça tombe trop monsieur de ses
anneaux excusez moi madame fouquet rni
pour qu'on fait pas plus de stockage
avec des pipelines pour irriguer et tout
ça le temps nous est compté c'est très
difficile de répondre aussi rapidement à
la promptitude à laquelle vous posez vos
questions
déjà merci trop rapide pour vous ne
défendez vos demeures en tout cas pour
moi déjà merci de de consacrer une
émission à la sécheresse parce que je
crois que ça n'est pas on en a parlé
beaucoup sur notre antenne où tu as fait
et je crois que ça n'est pas qu'une
affaire d'agriculteurs je pense que si
vraiment en tendance lourde
ce que nous avons vécu cet été doit se
reproduire de plus en plus souvent se
pose derrière cette affaire-là la
question de l'indépendance et de
l'autonomie alimentaire d'un pays donc
sa demande
delà de la concentration ça demande de
la convergence de force sans a priori
vous évoquez la question du stockage
d'eau c'est un coût d'investissement
c'est un coût de fonctionnement mais je
pense que c'est c'est là une piste qui
se répondent complètement à certains
types de productions je pense notamment
aux légumes aux légumes à proximité de
grandes métropoles avoir une retenue
collinaire qui permettent de recoller r
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
fait un barrage alors certes c'est
artificiel mais une retenue modestes
dont on profite pas on va pas exploré
toutes les pistes aujourd'hui comme vous
avez vous avez raison de le dire
le temps nous est compté il reste moins
de deux minutes et est ce qui me
semblait important c'est que vous qui
êtes donc des agriculteurs vous vous
adressiez on va commencer avec vous
monsieur decerle rapidement aux
agriculteurs qui serait au bout du
rouleau
parce qu'il ya un cas de suicide dans
votre profession qui est important en
quelques mots qu'est ce que vous avez à
leur dire et puis on va faire un tour de
table pour finir cette émission c'est
cette aux agriculteurs que vous me
donnez l'occasion parler je le fais
notre profession plus que tout autre a
su au fil des années elle l'a prouvé à
maintes et maintes reprises relever des
défis et des défis extrêmement complexe
on a oublié c'est pas si vieux qui est
des tickets de panneaux ce pays
aujourd'hui on gaspille l'alimentation
les agriculteurs ont rempli leur boulot
pour relever le défi de l'évolution
climatique y seront le fer si l'ensemble
des acteurs qui s'intéressent à cette
question là les attaques moins
violemment thierry celmins rapidement
rapidement déjà le meilleur remède est
effectivement ou désarroi des
agriculteurs ce serait de retrouver des
prix rémunérateurs parce que ceux dont
on souffre c'est notre difficulté ça
vous vous adressez à moi et aux pouvoirs
publics mais je me sens très bien que si
nous avions une difficulté financière et
économique - perpétuelle on pourrait
passer des caps difficiles quand on est
dans des événements climatiques et moi
je leur dis tout simplement aux
agriculteurs que c'est collectivement
qu'on s'en sortira et qu'il faut surtout
pas qu'ils se replient sur eux-mêmes
qu'il faut surtout pas qu'ils aient
perdu pied et que c'est dans
défense collective sans valise et un bon
collectif concours on va laisser un
petit mot très rapide à sophie
fonquernie on sait que les agriculteurs
sont les premiers impactés par le
réchauffement climatique et on est
derrière eux
toutes les collectivités derrière la
société pour soutenir les soutenir dans
ce moment difficile et on va trouver des
solutions avec la recherche avec
l'innovation avec la réflexion pour
s'adapter pour pouvoir qui est de mise
il ya encore des agriculteurs merci
madame merci messieurs fin de cette
émission bon dimanche après midi à tous
au revoir
[Musique]